on peut ressentir un sentiment de
lassitude de jour sans fin ont pu se
replonger dans les périodes difficiles
que nous avons vécu collectivement
depuis près de deux ans
oui le virus circule à nouveau les
simples vite il circule partout en
france et dans le monde à l'évidence ce
virus répond à des cycles émaillée de
périodes de flambées épidémiques et de
périodes d'accalmie
oui la france connaît à son tour une
cinquième bague
oui cette cinquième vague sera sans
conteste plus forte plus longue que la
quatrième vague est survenu cet été si
le vernir en cause de paris en taffetas
très contagieux est le même les
conditions climatiques automnale et
hivernale favorise sa diffusion d'autant
que nous passons davantage de temps à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
le professeur jérôme salomon va dans
quelques secondes vous donner tous les
éléments pour comprendre où nous en
sommes mais avant je veux vous dire
qu'il n'ya aucune fatalité face à ce qu
il ya des cycles depuis deux ans la
donne a changé et nous avons les moyens
de nous prémunir individuellement et
collectivement des conséquences
dramatiques
des premières vagues je veux vous dire
que nous avons encore notre destin entre
nos mains
grâce à l'une des couvertures esnal les
plus fortes au monde grâce au geste de
barrières grâce ou bas sanitaire ainsi
et suite au conseil de défense et de
sécurité nationale qui s'est tenue hier
je ne vous annoncerai ni confinement ni
gouffre feu ni fermeture anticipée des
commerces ni limitation des déplacements
à l'heure où nombre de nos voisins
européens font face à la vague la plus
violente depuis le début de la pandémie
et sont contraints de prendre de telles
mesures ty nous faisons le choix de
concilier liberté et responsabilité et
nous considérons aujourd'hui que nous
pouvons encore passer cette vague sans
recourir aux outils les plus
contraignants si nous savons utiliser
pleinement les cartes que nous avons en
main je vous présenterai dans quelques
minutes les décisions qui ont été prises
par le président de la république pour
protéger les français puis le ministre
de l'éducation nationale abordera la
question des écoles mais avant tout
professeur salon je vous laisse la
parole
l'europe confrontée à une importante
cinquième vague d'eau vide est re devenu
l'épicentre de la pandémie
les conditions hivernales
température humidité vent pollution avec
davantage d'activités et de
rassemblement en intérieur la baisse du
respect des mesures barrières le port du
masque aération régulière des locaux le
lavage des mains ne pas se faire la bise
se serrer la main et l'insuffisante
couverture vaccinale en tribut à cette
tendance internationale préoccupante le
vaccin est une arme très efficace pour
réduire le risque de formes graves ou de
décès mais son efficacité notamment
contre la transmission de la maladie
diminue avec le temps d'où l'importance
du rappel
les pays situés à l'est et au nord de
l'europe ont été les premiers touchés
faisant face depuis début octobre à une
flambée des contaminations l'autriche a
été contrainte de confiner sa population
la belgique les pays bas le danemark le
royaume uni ou encore l'allemagne dont
le taux d'incidence vient de dépasser
400 sont sévèrement touchés et
connaissent des situations de tension
dans les hôpitaux les pays d'europe
méridionale largement vacciner comme
l'espagne le portugal et l'italie
jusqu'ici épargnée par cette vague
connaissent également une remontée
rapide des cas ces derniers jours toute
l'europe est à présent concernés par
cette cinquième vague le taux
d'incidence sur sept jours ils dépassent
deux cent soixante dix pour cent mille
habitants alors qu'il est de 48 et demi
au niveau mondial l'europe représente
aujourd'hui 67 % des nouvelles
contaminations présent c'est que dans le
monde
cette vague touche désormais toute la
france métropolitaine de façon homogène
avec une incidence en forte hausse le
taux d'incidence s'élève à 193 et le r
effectifs la vitesse de propagation de
l'épidémie et 2006 ce qui se traduit par
un doublement du nombre de personnes
touchées
tous les 11 jours la barre des trente
six mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures a
été dépassé dès ce lundi elle correspond
au pic observé en août lors de la
quatrième vague
les nouvelles hospitalisations et
admission en soins critiques toujours
décalé de une deux semaines par rapport
aux cas sont aussi en nette augmentation
au niveau national
8765 malades de lakovic sont
hospitalisées dont 1483 en soins
critiques la transmission du virus
s'accélère l'impact sanitaire de cette
vague est réel les personnes aujourd'hui
hospitalisés sont essentiellement non
vaccinés âgées et/ou particulièrement
fragile immunodéprimés notables selon
les projections réalisées par l'institut
pasteur le pic de la quatrième vague de
patients atteints de colite graves
hospitalisés en soins critiques pourrait
être atteint dès début décembre donc la
semaine proche en france métropolitaine
l'impact sanitaire est réelle mais
nettement réduit grâce à la couverture
vaccinale importante et à l'efficacité
du vaccin et du rappel sur le risque de
décès de formes graves et
d'hospitalisations
il est en effet près de huit fois plus
d'entrées en soins critiques parmi les
personnes âgées de 20 ans ou plus non
vaccinés que parmi celles complètement
vaccinés le vaccin protège donc
fortement contre les formes graves avec
un risque / 8 risque encore diminué
après rappel depuis de nombreux mois
nous avons fait collectivement et
individuellement
de gros efforts qui nous l'avons vu ces
dernières semaines ont permis à notre
pays de retarder l'arrivée de cette
cinquième vague rapport à nos voisins
l'instauration et le contrôle du pass à
lithaire notre taux de vaccination parmi
les plus élevés en europe 88 % et 12 ans
et plus sont vaccinés neuf adultes sur
dix font partie de ces efforts a
souligné nous devons garder ce bénéfice
de la mobilisation en faveur de la
vaccination
reprenons aussi des réflexes de
prévention les gestes barrière cruciaux
tels que le port du masque en
particulier à l'intérieur la ra ce
régulière des locaux le lavage fréquent
des mains ne pas se faire la bise ou se
serrer la main
adoptons à nouveau nos bons
comportements de la stratégie tester a
été protégée au moindre doute au moindre
symptôme ou si je suis qu'à contacter je
me fais tester même si je suis vacciné
si je suis positif même vacciné je
m'isole immédiatement et je préviens
c'est l'addition de toutes ces mesures
vaccination pas sanitaire mesures
barrières tester isolement qui nous
permettra de freiner la diffusion du
virus est de nous protéger
collectivement le virus va continuer à
circuler activement pour des prochaines
semaines car nous le savons les
conditions métérologiques et nos
activités principalement en intérieur
font de l'hiver la saison idéale pour la
propagation de tous les virus notamment
la transmission respiratoires pour
passer les fêtes de fin d'année avec nos
proches dans les meilleures conditions
mobilisons nous individuellement et
collectivement
mobilisons nous pour protéger au mieux
ceux qui nous sont chers mobilisons nous
pour protéger nos professionnels de
santé sur le front de la pandémie depuis
près de deux ans est toujours là pour
nous soigner gérer l'importante activité
de l'hiver et les épidémies de covin
bronchiolite délais et quelques miettes
merci beaucoup à gérer mentalement alors
certains s'interrogent
comment une vague était impossible alors
que 90% d'entre nous âgé de 12 ans et
plus sont vaccinés est-ce que ça
signifierait que le vaccin serait
finalement moins efficace que prévu non
en fait il faut bien que vous compreniez
que si nous n'avions pas cette
couverture vaccinale importante nous
serions déjà foudroyé submergés par les
vagues qui des milk pascal barillon data
est extrêmement contagieux beaucoup plus
que le commis 19 et qu'à l'évidence nous
serions à cette heure-ci déjà
probablement même tous confinés puisque
des mots des faits et des preuves
la part de français en réanimation selon
qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non vacciner
jérôme seulement l'a dit par les mêmes
c'est un fait dans les patients admis à
l'hôpital pour cody la part des patients
vaccinés est dix fois moins fréquentes
que celles ils ont raffiné une réduction
par dix imaginez donc le nombre de
malades en réanimation avec la vague
épidémique mais la quatrième deux cet
été si nous n'avions pas une couverture
vaccinale optimale par ailleurs nous
savons avec l'exemple allemand qu'il
existe une corrélation très nette entre
la couverture vaccinale dans un
territoire et l'intensité de circulation
du virus dans un territoire plus les
régions allemandes sont vaccinées moins
il ya de cas et moins vieux camarades et
moi je me sens vacciné il ya des grandes
différences en allemagne d'une région à
une autre plus il y a deux cas graves et
de la même manière d'ailleurs en france
on est capable d'objectiver à l'échelle
du bassin de vie dans des territoires
que là où la vaccination est plus faible
parce qu'il ya une tradition vaccinale
moins forte par exemple eh bien c'est là
qu'on enregistre les taux d'incidence
est le nombre de cas graves le plus
important donc ça veut dire que le
vaccin ne protège il ne faut pas il ne
faut plus en douter si vous aviez encore
des doutes là dessus il nous protège
individuellement en réduisant très
fortement le risque de développer une
forme grave et d'être hospitalisée et
nous protège collectivement parce qu'il
est réduit la circulation du virus ne
l'année en dit pas et circulation il
avait réduit très fortement et donc ça
va lui aussi le risque de contaminer
autour de nous des personnes qui serait
fragile et qui pourrait développer des
formes graves ça veut dire que même si
je suis jeune je veux vacciner pour
protéger moi même mais aussi pour
protéger toutes les personnes que je
peux rencontrer au quotidien et qui
elles ne sont peut-être pas suffisamment
protégé le vaccin est donc très
protecteur mais il est vrai aussi que
son efficacité va diminuer avec le temps
ce qui est un phénomène classique avec
les vaccins en effet un vaccin apprend à
votre système immunitaire à votre corps
à fabriquer des armes contre le virus
qu'on appelle des anticorps qui fait que
si le virus se présente vous êtes déjà
armé vous savez fabriquer ses armes pour
le virus et voulait empêcher de vous
infecter mais avec un petit peu au bout
d'un certain temps l'efficacité du
vaccin elle diminue votre mémoire
immunitaire n est pas infaillible et
donc il ya un premier rappel qui est
fait pour dire au système immunitaire
souviens toi comment est ce que tu
fabriques et ces anticorps contre le
virus est bien ce que nous savons c'est
que dans le cadre des virus et des
vaccins contre le coc ville au bout de
quelques mois il faut renouveler ce
rappel pour réactiver la mémoire
immunitaire et alors on va avoir une
démultiplication de l'efficacité de
l'immunité et ce dès les premières
heures qui suivent le rappel de
vaccination c'est très impressionnant de
voir cela l'immunité ps on est moins
protégé ou quelques mois et d'un seul
coup avec le rappel immunité redevient
absolument optimale du coup les
scientifiques en france comme à
l'étranger considèrent désormais qu'elle
se rappelle il est utile chez tous les
adultes chez tout le monde dès 18 ans
parce que l'immunité même chez les
adultes jeunes elle commence à décliner
au bout de quelques mois et dans le
contexte de forte circulation de virus
que nous connaissions les autorités
typhi considère aussi que ce rappel il
faut pas attendre six mois pour le faire
il vaut mieux le faire des cinq mois
après la dernière injection ou après
avoir été infectés d'ailleurs la haute
autorité de santé que j'avais saisi sur
la question vient à l'instant de publier
des recommandations qui sont celles que
nous indique et qui sont que la première
annonce que je vous fais ce matin que se
confirme c'est que désormais le rappel
vaccinal sera ouvert à tous les adultes
âgés de 18 ans et plus des cinq mois
après leur dernière injection ce qui
veut dire qu en pratique cela concerne
25 millions de français 25 millions
français dont 6 millions ont déjà reçu
leur appel il reste donc 10 9 millions
français à date qui deviennent éligibles
ou le rappel de vaccination et que nous
invitons donc à se faire vacciner dans
les deux prochains mois
certains d'entre vous s'interrogent si
j'ai été affecté par le cos vide puisque
je dois quand même c'est mon rappel la
règle est simple et revenez l'a bien une
infection correspond à une injection
pourquoi parce que si vous avez été
affectés de la même manière votre
système immunitaire apprend à fabriquer
des anticorps des armes contre le virus
et donc une infection peut donner une
protection équivalente à celle procurée
par le vaccin ce qui veut dire que si
vous avez été infectés vous avez une
dose et que vous êtes à cinq mois de la
dose de l'interjection recevez un appel
si vous avez reçu une première injection
qui ensuite vous avez une copie de cinq
mois après vous recevez votre rappel si
vous avez eu deux injections et que vous
avez eu malgré tout le quotid dans cinq
mois vous pourrez bénéficier d'un rappel
c'est une règle qui est clair qui est
simple et qui s'appliquent à tous les
adultes âgés de 18 ans et plus en
parallèle nous voulons continuer d'aller
chercher vraiment mobiliser les quelques
six millions d'entre nous qui ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées alors qu'ils sont
éligibles depuis bientôt un an quelles
que soient les craintes quelles que
soient les réticences n'est plus temps
d'attendre ni avec cinq français pour
certains ni d'avoir suffisamment de
recul on est bientôt un an la campagne
vaccinale des milliards de terriens ont
été vaccinées vous savez que ce vaccin
est efficace vous savez qui vous protège
vous savez ce qui vous entoure on va
continuer de mobiliser tout ce qu'on
peut pour aller vous motiver la région
voir ce vaccin on va développer à
nouveau des opérations avec des
médiateurs sanitaires à destination des
personnes fragiles isolées en lien avec
des collectivités territoriales on va re
développer des barnums de vaccination
notamment dans les centres commerciaux
parce que ça fonctionne bien on
j'appelle à nouveau et je sensibilise à
nouveau et je sais qu'ils le font au
quotidien les médecins les pharmaciens
les internés à les motiver leurs
patients réfractaires pour qu'il puisse
se perdre et thiney et solennellement
j'appelle celles et ceux d'entre vous
notamment des plus âgés et les plus
fragiles qui hésitiez encore à franchir
le pas parce que ce virus tue et que ce
médecin vous protège
l'autre question qui peut se poser c'est
ce que nous avons suffisamment de
vaccins pour vacciner ses 19 millions de
français eh bien oui nous avons
suffisamment de vaccins plus de 25
millions de vaccins arn messagers sont
actuellement stockés dans les
établissements santé mais également de
chez les médecins et les pharmacies en
ville des os des doses de pfizer et des
doses moderna là aussi je rassure tout
le monde à partir de 30 ans on peut
recevoir un rappel avec du moderna qui
est un vaccin extrêmement efficace ces
rappels peuvent se faire donc auprès de
tous les professionnels de santé
habilités à vacciner en ville les
médecins dans quinze mille pharmacie du
territoire les sages femmes les
infirmiers les masseurs
kinésithérapeutes les laboratoires de
biologie
ces professionnels de vieller qui
peuvent commander désormais autant de
vaccins qu'ils le souhaitent et ce
depuis plusieurs semaines et on estime
qu' environ 4 millions de doses de
vaccins arn messager qui font
actuellement en stock chez vos
professionnels de santé en ville si vous
le souhaitez vous pouvez aussi opter
pour les centres de vaccination ils
rêvent plus de 1100 centres ouverts sur
tout le territoire national la france
reste l'un des pays les mieux mailler en
centres de vaccination et avec les élus
locaux avec kim que nous avons concerté
ce matin même avec le premier ministre
avec les ars avec les préfets nous
allons ouvrir rouvrir ou amplifier les
centres de vaccination existants et ce
dès ce week-end caf la vaccination en
rappel pour les adultes est ouverte à
compter de ce samedi et vous pouvez
d'ores et déjà vous rendre sur les
plates formes de prise de rendez vous en
ligne pour réserver au créneau vous
comme nous le savons tous le monde
évidemment les 19 millions français
appelés à se faire vacciner ne pourront
pas être vaccinés aujourd'hui ou demain
ça va prendre un petit peu de temps et
c'est tout à fait normal et ce n'est pas
grave c'est d'ailleurs la traduction de
votre mobilisation mais je vous le redis
il y aura des vaccins pour tout le monde
tout le monde pourra être vaccinés dans
les télés vacciner revacciner des
millions et des millions de français en
quelques semaines
c'est certes une prouesse une prouesse
logistique mais si tu me prouver ce que
nous avons déjà réalisé ce printemps et
cet été grâce à l'extraordinaire
mobilisation de nos professionnels de
santé drs
préfet des élus locaux des agents des
collectivités territoriales que je
remercie à nouveau pour leur très grande
mobilisation et ce à compter de ce
week-end qui sera à nouveau renforcé
notre question pour la vaccination ça
contient la vaccination des 5 11 ans
d'assignation des enfants l'agencé
européenne du médicament communiquera
aux alentours de 15 ou 16 heures en
disant qu'elle considère manifestement
j'attends l'avis définitif de la
vaccination peut être ouverte dans des
conditions de sécurité pour les enfants
âgés de 5 à 11 ans quelles sont
désormais les étapes à suivre en france
d'abord je saisis le conseil consultatif
national d'éthique parce qu'il ya des
questions éthiques qu'il se pose en
termes de protection collective de
protection individuelle s'agissant des
enfants ensuite je saisis bien sûr la
haute autorité de santé pour qu'elle
puisse regarder décrypter en toute
transparence l'ensemble des données à
disposition et déterminer dans quel
cadre dans quel contexte pourrait ou non
être ouverte la vaccination aux enfants
de 5 à 11 ans dans tous les cas cette
vaccination si elle était décidée en
france ne commencerait pas avant le
début de l'année 2022 puisqu'il faut
pour cela recevoir les vaccins avec des
dilutions de vaccins adaptés aux enfants
les règles concernant le pass sanitaires
vont quant à elles et en cohérence
évolué vous le savez à compter du 15
décembre le passage du ter pour les plus
de 65 ans ne sera plus actif si le
rappelle n'a pas été fait dans un délai
de sept mois après l'injection ou après
la dernière injection
il à compter du 15 janvier se passe
d'annie terre de tous les autres publics
c'est à dire les français âgés de 8 à 64
ans ne sera plus actif si le rappelle
n'a pas été fait dans ce délai qui reste
inchangé de sept mois après la dernière
injection de sorte qu'une fois vous êtes
à cinq mois de votre dernier objections
vous aurez deux mois pour recevoir votre
rappel et ainsi conserver le bénéfice de
votre pass sanitaires par ailleurs et à
compter de lundi 29 novembre lundi
prochain les tests pcr et antigénique
qui donne accès aux pastels iter dont
celles et ceux qui parmi vous n'êtes pas
encore vaccinés aujourd'hui sont
valables 72 heures avant que c'était
valable 48 heures qu'on peut dire le
circuit un peu plus compte tenu du fait
que le virus circule beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui nous dit nous réduisons à 24
heures la durée du de ceux de validité
de ces tests pour bénéficier du pass
annie terre ce qui veut dire qu'une très
concrètement si vous n'êtes pas encore
vaccinés et si vous souhaitez bénéficier
du pass à lithaire vous devrez donc vous
faire tester tous les jours à vos frais
sauf si vous êtes symptomatique avec une
ordonnance de votre médecin sauf si vous
êtes reconnu qu'à contacter par l'
agence régionale de santé ou par
l'assurance maladie
la vaccination est notre meilleure arme
notre meilleure protection le passé
nucléaire est une arme supplémentaire
qui est efficace et qu'il est montré
dans toutes les études mais nous devons
pousser notre avantage face au co vide
jusqu'au bout ce n'est pas la seule arme
dont nous disposons je parlais des
gestes barrières du masque et de
l'aération des mesures simples qu'il
appartient à chacun d'entre nous de
respecter au quotidien et dans la durée
et pour lesquels a relativement
compréhensible quand le virus circule et
moins est constatée nous devons donc
collectivement nous ressaisir et nous
avons je le répète notre destin en
chacun est responsable de la santé du
groupe et nous sommes tous en premier
dans le combat contre le virus
être libre ce n'est pas refusé mordicus
ces mesures qui évite de saturer les
services de réanimation et qui
permettent de retrouver une vie aussi
normale que possible ces petites
contraintes du quotidien sont les clés
de notre liberté être libre c'est
d'abord être responsable essai mesuré la
portée de nos choix nos services de
réanimation accueille des centaines de
patients qui étaient libres de passeurs
vacciner des patients d'ailleurs parfois
un jeune qui ont préféré la croyance à
la science qui ont préféré la conviction
à la responsabilité sont ils libres
aujourd'hui je ne le fera pas il est
dommage de mettre sa vie en danger pour
une idée fausse de manière générale et
c'est pour cela que je vous parle de
responsabilité je sais aussi que les
gestes barrière peuvent vous paraître
parfois dérisoires par rapport à un
virus auxquels nous faisons face depuis
près de deux ans mais ils sont d outil
inestimable dans le fait de freiner la
propagation du but vide hélas nos
copines ne s'arrête pas de circuler
parce que c'est l'heure d'un moment de
convivialité à l'issue d'une longue
réunion autour d'un verre hélas de
retour des poignées de mains ne transmet
pas que la chaleur humaine il peut
transmettre aussi le virus il faut donc
rester vigilant à tout instant reprendre
les bonnes habitudes qui ont parfois été
perdu le gel hydroalcoolique du aussi
doit faire son retour partout où on
constate qu'il est pas hélas parfois de
lui permit de certains endroits nous
manquons clairement pas de gel donc il
nous faut en consommer un maximum
le masque lui aussi a été
progressivement voter notamment entre
des personnes vaccinées qui se disent
bon toi tu est vacciné je suis vacciné
au risque peut rien lève le masque cette
presse est opéré progressivement par
usure par fausse réassurance désormais
contenu de la circulation du virus il
faut leur mettre d'ailleurs à ce titre
est à compter de demain un décret rendra
à nouveau obligatoire le port du masque
partout en intérieur dans les lieux
couverts par un pass à lithaire donc
même en cas de passe à lutter dans un
lieu recevant du public vous devrez
porter le masque les préfets seront
aussi habilités département par
département à rendre obligatoire le port
du masque en extérieur pour des
événements en extérieur tels que par
exemple on peut l'imaginer dans les
prochaines semaines les marchés de noël
ou encore des brocantes s'agissant
d'ailleurs des marchés de noël leur
accès sera lui aussi désormais soumis au
passage du ter
je disais parmi les autres mesures
barrières et à l'aération est une mesure
qui est essentielle elle permet des
actus et les particules de virus en
suspension dans l'air on doit tous
adoptés ou réadopté ce réflexe d'aérer
souvent partout par exemple si vous avez
une réunion qui dure une heure vous
prenez la peine d'ouvrir une fenêtre
même s'il fait un peu froid s'est
désisté en vous ouvrez dix minutes la
fenêtre et ça permet l'évacuation des
particules virales et ça réduit le
risque de contamination par ailleurs
partout où c'est nécessaire il peut être
utile d'installer des capteurs de co2 ça
ne permet pas à l'aération mais ça
permet de vous alerter quand il est
devenu urgent d'aérer les autres gestes
barrières sont tout autant utile on lui
rappelle jérôme simplement tousser ou
éternuer dans son cou d'utiliser un
mouchoir à usage unique bref vaccination
pas sanitaire gestes barrières nous
avons d'ores et déjà les armes pour
combattre cette nouvelle vague mais dans
les prochaines semaines nous disposerons
d'une arme supplémentaire
depuis le début de l'épidémie les
laboratoires du monde entier cherchent
des traitements qu'ils sont efficace
contre le candide la recherche a là
aussi réalisé des progrès considérables
et je tiens je tiens le dirait france
est à chaque fois à la pointe pour être
l'un des premiers pays au monde en faire
bénéficier les malades depuis quelques
mois nous disposons ainsi d'un
traitement à base d'anticorps dirigés
contre le virus un traitement injectable
qui nécessitent d'être hospitalisée et
qui permet de diminuer les risques de
développer des formes l'âge et les
personnes particulièrement à risque plus
de 7000 français ont reçu monsieur type
de traitement mais la donne a changé
puisque à partir du début du mois de
décembre nous avons l'arrivée d'un
nouveau médicament cette fois ci c'était
un médicament antiviral il s'appelle le
môle du pire à venir et nous fondons
beaucoup d'espoir dans ce traitement
c'est un médicament qui étant comprimé
qui pourraient être prescrits par la
médecine de ville par vos médecins
généralistes qui sera disponible dans
les pharmacies d'officine en ville c'est
un médicament qui sera réservé aux
personnes qui sont à risque de faire des
formes graves ou par leur âge plus de 65
ans ou parce qu'ils ont des maladies
chroniques vos médecins recevront toutes
les indications et les règles de
prescription de ce médicament et pour
les gens qui sont concernés dont qui
sont à risque de formes graves et qui
présentent des symptômes une formes
symptomatiques de co lead ce médicament
s'il est administré dans les cinq
premiers jours les études cliniques
montrent qui peut réduire par deux le
risque d'être hospitalisé je tiens à
dire à aussi la france sera le premier
pays européen en faire bénéficier ses
citoyens d'autres traitements vont
arriver dans les prochains mois à base
ou d'anticorps ou d'anti viraux qui
viendront renforcer
personal protocole mesdames messieurs
nous sommes prêts nous ne sommes pas
désarmés nous ne sommes pas démunis nous
avons des outils pour la combattre cette
cinquième vague les gestes barrière
l'agression à tous les étages les
vaccins des tests et désormais c'est un
immense espoir les traitements si nous
parvenons à mobiliser tous ses outils si
nous agissons en liberté et en
responsabilité nous pouvons réussir à
franchir cette vague sans davantage de
mesures de contrainte pour la population
c'est notre voeu le plus cher je sais
qu'il est partagé par celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent et nous regardent
aujourd'hui donc soyons mobilisés soyons
solidaires soyons courageux une fois de
plus nous l'avons été par le passé nous
le serons encore dans les prochains
jours et les prochaines semaines je vous
remercie et je passe la parole à vos
collègues jean-michel blanquer cela vous
parler de la question particulière des
écoles
bien mesdames messieurs l'évolution de
l'épidémie dont nous parlons depuis tout
à l'heure concerne évidemment l'école
comme le reste de la société et comme
nous l'avons fait depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire nous allons donc ajuster
notre protocole pour tenir compte de
cette réalité notre objectif notre
boussole vous le savez bien reste la
priorité d'une école ouverte c'est ce
que nous avons fait tout au long de
l'année dernière c'est ce que font
désormais d'ailleurs tous les pays
européens donc toutes les mesures dont
je parlerai ensuite sont guidés par cet
objectif mais tout d'abord je voudrais
faire un point sur l'état de la
situation sanitaire dans l'espace
scolaire nous avons aujourd'hui en
france pour les plus de 12 ans les 12 17
ans un taux de vaccination élevé c'est
l'une des meilleures couvertures
vaccinales en europe pour cette classe
d'âge derrière la péninsule ibérique
nous avons ainsi 77% de primo vacciner
75 % avec un schéma vaccinal complet
pour rappel la moyenne de la couverture
vaccinale en europe ses 55% c'est
évidemment un atout pour l'enseignement
secondaire où ces élèves sont vaccinés
je voulais je voudrais signaler aussi
que la vaccination des professeurs
atteint 90% dans la dernière enquête que
nous avons fait ce qui est largement
supérieur à la moyenne nationale et donc
merci là aussi aux professeurs pour leur
civisme et leur sens des responsabilités
bien sûr les campagnes vaccinales
continueront et ces chiffres peuvent
encore augmenter à ce jour donc la
situation et pimpante et en croissance
et hier ont dénombré 8 1500 classes
fermées ce chiffre était de 4100 le 19
novembre je rappelle que au pic de la
crise dans dernier nous jusqu'à douze
mille classes fermées cela donc restent
inférieurs à certains pics que nous
avons connus mais c'est une tendance en
rosé bon nous sommes attentifs ces
fermetures de classes concerne
exclusivement casier vivement l'école
primaire je voudrais rappeler le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
dans l'espace scolaire depuis la rentrée
de septembre avec évidemment une grande
différence entre l'école primaire et
l'enseignement sur vous pour l'année
2000 21 2022 nous avons établi en lien
avec les autorités sanitaires un
protocole graduée comportant quatre
niveaux et le passage d'un niveau à
l'autre dépend de différents facteurs
notamment le taux d'incidence de
dépistage la couverture vaccinale
l'attention des structures hospitalières
et d'autres critères encore le protocole
sanitaire qui s'applique en métropole
actuellement est de niveau 2 et il
comprend des mesures dont certaines sont
bien connus et recoupent ceux que nous
venons d'entendre population générale je
pense en particulier aux mesures
renforcées d'aération ce qui vient
d'être dit sur les salles vaut
évidemment pour les salles de classe
c'est à dire l'ouverture des fenêtres le
plus fréquemment possible et notamment
une fois par heure le lavage des mains
le port du masque obligatoire tous les
personnels ainsi que pour les élèves dès
le cours préparatoire
la limitation du brassage par niveau la
désinfection des surfaces les plus
touchées et en mesures diverses
l'absence de sport de contact et des
distanciation adeptes
ce protocole dont continuent à
s'appliquer et il est complété par un
protocole de traçage du vise à
identifier les cas de kovy déclaré et
les cas contacts rappelons que l'an
dernier avant le déploiement des vaccins
c'était notre principal levier notre
fameuse stratégie testé à les protéger
est ce qui nous a permis de maintenir
pour l'essentiel des colonnettes selon
ce protocole un cadre que vit dans une
classe à l'école primaire en traîneau
aujourd'hui la fermeture d'une classe
est au collège et au lycée les élèves
justifiant d'une vacciner complète pour
suivre leurs cours en présence et les
contacts à risque sans vaccination passe
à l'enseignement à distance pour une
durée de sept jours
aujourd'hui donc au collège et au lycée
la cinquième vague à moins d'impact
grâce notamment la vaccination et grâce
au protocole mis en place et donc c'est
sûr l'école primaire que je vais
maintenant insisté puisque
l'enseignement secondaire avec le
protocole actuel de tout à fait
traverser la cinquième
aujourd'hui pour l'école primaire de
nombreuses familles sont concernées par
les fermetures qui existe nous estimons
que cette environ 180 mille familles
sont concernées aujourd'hui par des
fermetures de classes et vous savez je
suis très conscient et très attentif à
cette réalité
hier nous avions trois mille deux cents
élèves étaient déclarés positifs sont
donc des chiffres qui sont assez
importants
c'est pourquoi depuis plusieurs semaines
nous avons lancé une expérimentation
dans dix départements depuis le début du
mois d'octobre exactement pour tester un
dispositif plus adapté et qui nous avait
été inspiré par les autorités sanitaires
et scientifiques lorsqu'un élève et
testé positif tous les élèves de la
classe sont testés à leur tour et donc
seuls les camarades restés positifs
restent à la maison
ce dispositif montre sa pertinence nous
en aurons les résultats complets avec
santé publique france le 3 décembre mais
déjà nous pouvons en tirer quelques
leçons dès lors que nous sommes capables
de l'adapter aux réalités concrètes que
nous constaterons car on retire deux
enseignements d'abord il apparaît
important et pertinent de mettre en
place pour les élèves de l'école
primaire parce que ça permet de limiter
l'impact en termes de ferme de classe et
ça permet de maintenir le même niveau de
protection des élèves mais on doit
adapter les modalités de dépistage parce
que selon les départements nous avons
constaté des réalités différentes
notamment capacité de réactivité des
laboratoires des différentes structures
concernées par ce dispositif est donc le
dispositif nouveau que nous allons
mettre en place à partir de la semaine
prochaine nous en avons parlé ce matin
même encore avec les collectivités
locales et représentants des
collectivités locales au travers de
leurs associations d'élus que je
remercie de même nous en avons parlé ce
matin avec les organisations
représentatives de l'éducation nationale
et les organisations de parents d'élèves
ce dispositif est donc conçu pour
assurer à la fois la protection de nos
élèves et de nos concitoyens et en même
temps une ouverture aussi grande que
possible de nos écoles primaires il
n'aura donc plus de fermeture
systématique de classes dès le premier
cadre vide en primaire mais un dépistage
systématique de toute la classe
autrement dit seuls les élèves
présentant un test négatif pourront
revenir en classe ces tests pourront
être réalisés par les responsables
légaux et donc c'est une mesure de
souplesse c'est à dire que le test peut
être réalisée soit par les responsables
les mots en général les parents au
travers des pharmacies des laboratoires
de l'ensemble des structures qui
réalisent des thèses soit au travers
d'une présence des laboratoires dans
l'établissement scolaire dans l'école
primaire c'est ce que ceux qui se
précisera et se réalisera tout au long
de la semaine prochaine cette mesure
entrera en vigueur dans le courant de la
semaine prochaine de manière
différenciée selon les lieux puisque la
mobilisation des structures adaptées des
différentes selon les et bien entendu
aussi bien les communes que les
directeurs et directrices d'école au
travers des recteurs seront informés des
modalités je rappelle que le test est
gratuit il est gratuit pour tous les
mineurs et que évidemment tous les
mineurs seront mis en situation de
pouvoir être testé le protocole de
niveau 2 est donc maintenue sur tout le
territoire il s'applique aussi à l'école
primaire avec cette évolution du
protocole de traçage ces nouvelles
mesures nous permettent d'ajuster notre
dispositif pour faire face à l'évolution
de la situation épidémique nous devons
être évidemment particulièrement
vigilante dans les prochains jours sur
la vise à limiter le nombre de
fermetures de classes à l'école primaire
on sait que c'est préjudiciable aux
élèves cela vise aussi à responsabiliser
tout le monde de façon à ce qu'il y ait
finalement plus de tests réalisés pour
les enfants dans notre pays je sais que
nous pouvons compter sur la
responsabilité de chacun ça a été
réalisée dans le passé au travers
d'autres mesures qui remonteraient ce
sens des responsabilités des acteurs de
l'éducation c'est grâce à la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des membres
de la communauté éducative les chefs
d'établissements les directeurs et
directrices d'école les professeurs et
personnels les parents des élèves eux
mêmes dont on doit rappeler qu'ils font
preuve de beaucoup de civisme dans cette
période que les variations plus
particulièrement respectée dans
l'enceinte scolaire que dans le reste
dans la société que nous pouvons donc
être un des pays au monde pouvant
continuer à avoir au maximum ces écoles
ouvertes et donc au nom de l'intérêt des
enfants je veux remercier toutes et tous
pour la mobilisation que tout cela va
requérir je vous remercie
merci beaucoup jean pierre blanc terre
et on va prendre des questions si vous
en avez
ce
monsieur des ministres ma question
s'adresse à olivier ferrand c'est quoi
ne pas assumer que ce pas sanitaire est
un pass vaccinale qui ne dit pas son nom
et combien de temps allons-nous devoir
vivre encore soupe assad et à mesure
était censé être temporaire enfin est-ce
que grâce à ces durcissements vous
annoncer aujourd'hui vous fait dire aux
français qu'ils ne seront ni leur confie
n'est ni sous couvre-feu de rennes alors
que nombre de nos voisins européens vous
l'avez rappelé sont déjà arrivés là
d'abord je grossis c'est important nous
avons encore notre destin entre nos
mains nous considérons et d'ailleurs les
banalisation qui sont faites par
l'institut pasteur montrent que le rap
la matinale l'effet booster sur la
vaccination la protection collective et
individuelle très rapide art je redis
d'un thé les premières heures ou 48
heures on retrouve un niveau de
protection optimale contre contre
l'infection quand on a reçu son rappel
peut nous permettre de passer une vague
épidémique intense sans avoir de
saturation des hôpitaux samedi on a
encore notre destin en main
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que le choix
qui est fait c'est lui la responsabilité
et de la liberté est pas celui des
mesures de contrainte tête vous avez
raison de souligner l ont pu être mises
en place en autriche qui est en
confinement généralisée en allemagne qui
détermine à fermeture certains
établissements recevant du public ou
encore d'autres pays près de nous qu'ils
mettent en place des mesures qu'il
couvre feu donc vraiment nous estimons
que nous avons sept cette voie de
passage à travers cette cinquième vague
comme nous l'avons fait lors de la
quatrième vague où il n'y a pas eu de
mesures de contrainte collective des
mesures qui reposerait sur les personnes
vaccinées sur les personnes non
vaccinées sur le passé militaire ses
parties de pour certains effectivement
des mesures de contrainte je peux le
comprendre quand on n'est pas vacciné
qui soit contraignant de devoir se faire
tester pour accéder à un établissement
recevant du public jeudi c'est encore
plus contraignants pour les français qui
sont 90% à avoir été vacciné équivaut à
nouveau le virus circule et est à
nouveau des soins qui pourrait être
déprogrammée ou des hôpitaux qui
pourrait revoir arrivée des malades par
dizaines ou par centaines donc je le
redis le choix la responsabilité c'est
le choix la vaccination néanmoins la
différence fondamentale entre le pass
sanitaire une passerelle final fait
qu'il ya toujours la possibilité nous
quelqu'un qui n'est pas vacciné de se
faire tester certes assez frais pour
pouvoir accéder à un événement un
établissement recevant du public ou
rentrer dans un bar ou dans un
restaurant cette différence avec elle
est de taille pour un grand nombre de
français mais je souhaite que nous ayons
pu lui poser la question et nous nous
poserons encore moins la question du
pass sanitaire dans lorsque tout le
monde aura été vaccinées n'est qu'un
signe nous verrons peut-être des
épidémies de dengue épidémique gtx comme
idée était cyclique il aura peut-être
d'autres vagues dans le futur
probablement et que nous pourrons
affronter ces vagues beaucoup plus
sereinement parce que nous aurons tous
protégés
bonjour marie centrer pour tf1 lci ma
question s'adresse à vous monsieur
monsieur verront une question sur la
dose de rappel et ouverture donc aux
plus de 18 ans l ouverture de massif de
nouveaux créneaux vous l'avez évoqué
mais alors vous parlez la plate forme
par exemple d'octo libre est d'ores et
déjà encombré beaucoup s'inquiètent de
ces prises de rendez vous alors quand
ces créneaux vont-ils ouvrir un combien
de centres vont rouvrir également est ce
qu'on pourra parler d'ouverture de
nouveaux vaccinodromes comme il en avait
été le cas il ya quelques mois alors je
le redis nous étions montés à 1600
centres de vaccination la ville
participaient pas encore beaucoup à la
patrie nabeul qu'ils étaient ils étaient
limités en termes de commandes de
vaccins
aujourd'hui l'as 1100 centres donc ça va
être un maillage territorial qui est
très bon je les dis nous avons renforcé
par tous est nécessaire les centres
créés des nouvelles lignes de
vaccination la moyenne ont été supprimés
éventuellement couvrir d'autres centres
d'art où ils avaient été fermés comme ça
fait sens mais nous appuyons si
massivement vers un transfert vers la
ville vers vos pharmaciens et en 15000
des médecins etc sont des milliers et
des milliers vais je les ai tous cités
tout à l'heure une professionnelle de
santé numéro sept sommets de la semaine
dernière il faut commander un million et
demi de vaccins sur une semaine et à
yzeure la semaine demandez un devis dans
chaque sens ils ont au moins 4 millions
de vaccins disponibles donc les français
peuvent déjà s'adresser à leur médecin à
leur pharmacien dans infirmiers versa
cheval blanc kiné ils peuvent aussi
prendre rendez-vous dans les centres
lady nous avons armes et des centres de
la bonne manière pour pouvoir répondre à
toutes les demandes et je redis 1.4
fondamentale qui n'est pas la même
situation qu'il ya un an c'est que nous
avons en stock à l'heure à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle suffisamment de
vaccins pour vacciner tout le monde et
que il y à une période de deux mois qui
s'ouvre qui va permettre à chacun d'être
vaccinés qui veut dire qu'on a fait des
projections en montant à trois millions
et demi 4 millions de vaccinations par
semaine nous retrouvons des rythmes de
vaccination analogues à ceux que nous
avons connus au printemps et à l'été
c'est très bien de façon pas très bien
mais n'est pas très étonnant que des
sites de réservation en ligne soit
saturé à l'heure à laquelle je confirme
la danse de l'ouverture du rappel
vaccinal parce que figurez vous que je
reçois beaucoup plus beaucoup plus de
messages et de courrier depuis des jours
ou des semaines de la part de français
qui a des moins de 50 ans et qui voulait
être protégé en recevant entonnera de
nos deux rappelle que du courrier de la
part de gens qui ne veulent pas être
affiné qui ne veulent pas du passé
habité majorité c'est 90% des français
qui sont fascinés les intentions de
rappels de vaccination dans les enquêtes
d'opinion que nous faisons donc la quasi
totalité de celles et ceux qui ont eu
déjà deux doses et tout at il est tout à
fait prête à recevoir une troisième de
l'eau d'ailleurs créé spontanément les
personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus qui
étaient invités à recevoir un rappel les
trois quarts d'entre elles avaient déjà
fait le rappel dans le mois qui suit il
est donc encore une fois pas de stress
pas de panique si nos sites sature ça va
être rétablie dans les prochaines
minutes les prochaines heures on a vu ça
à chaque fois qu avec des annonces comme
celle ci ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une
appétence des français vous avez deux
mois et pendant les deux mois qui vont
arriver chacun pourra avoir été vaccinée
en bonne et due forme
prabonnaud france télévisions j'aurai
deux questions pour vous monsieur blanc
caire d'abord est-ce que vous envisagez
des tests systématiques dans les écoles
on se souvient des modèles de l'équipe
de vitoria colza qui montrait que c'est
efficace pour limiter les contaminations
et la deuxième est ce que vous envisagez
impasse sanitaires pour les enseignants
et une petite précision que vous
monsieur les rangs est-ce que les
masques sont obligatoires ou
redeviennent seront obligatoires en tout
les sacs de sport et les boîtes de nuit
bien merci pour ces deux questions sur
le sur la première vous faites référence
à l'étude de la cotisation en effet
l'étude de référence pour ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et ça a été
l'étude de référence pour
l'expérimentation dont je viens de
parler
je livrerai les détails dans comme je
vous le disais le 3 décembre à la suite
de santé publique france mais d'ores et
déjà ce que l'on peut dire c'est que
l'expérimentation dans dix départements
et très instructive à la fois par les
forces et par les limites que selon les
forces parce que en effet ça permet
d'éviter de fermer des classes mais les
limites parce que parfois
n'arrivons pas nous collectivement
n'arrivons pas à ce que l'ensemble des
acteurs nécessaires soient présents dans
les 24 heures pour faire les tests à
tous à tous les enfants donc cela permet
d'avoir des conclusions opérationnelles
et pour être à la fois souple et
pragmatique ce que nous en déduisons
c'est que oui nous allons finalement
suivre les principes qui était prônée
par le professeur colza mais nous le
faisons avec deux modalités finalement
une modalité que nous connaissons déjà
et que nous pratiquons c'est-à-dire un
laboratoire qui vient et qui permet de
tester tous les enfants ou une autre
modalité quand la première modalité
n'est pas possible c'est à dire demander
aux parents en ville de faire de faire
tester des enfants et donc l'enfant peut
revenir avec un test négatif ça nous
permet d'étendre les vertus de cette
expérimentation à toute la france tout
en étant pragmatique sur sur la manière
de le faire bien entendu nous allons
continuer à être volontariste sur notre
capacité à déployer des tests avec en
partenariat avec les laboratoires dans
dans les écoles mais jusqu'à présent on
a parfois rencontrer aussi les limites
par exemple dans le volontariat des
parents même pour des tests salivaires
donc là nous pensons que second carrière
des plus grands à partir du moment où
s'il enfin tester ça permet de revenir
en classe
ce qui est évidemment quelque chose
d'important pour tous donc ça c'est pour
votre première question et puis votre
votre deuxième question c'est donc sur
le le passe à lithaire nous avons dit
depuis le début que le que l'école était
un lieu particulier un sanctuaire où par
définition
chacun venait de manière ouverte même si
évidemment cela supposait le civisme de
tous c'est pourquoi j'ai souligné tout à
l'heure le taux de vaccination des
préférés des professeurs qui reste
important sur le moins de 10% terrestre
je les appelle évidemment à se vacciner
et au fait que continueront des
campagnes de vaccination dans le cadre
scolaire ou à côté des établissements
scolaires de manière à ce que les
adultes qui sont pas seulement les
professeurs d'ailleurs c'est l'ensemble
des personnels travaillant dans les
établissements
et les élèves ne puissent continuer à
être vaccinés chaque fois que nécessaire
sur la question qui m'était destinée sur
les masques et je le dis le décret
demain rendre obligatoire le port du
masque dans tous les lieux fermés y
compris les lieux qui sont soumis au
passé ni terre les conditions pratiques
précise mme établissement par
établissement seront précisées dans les
heures qui vont suivre il ya une
concertation avec l'ensemble du secteur
s'il faut compléter la question la
réponse à la question d'une défaite tout
à l'heure sur les prises de rendez vous
il y aura aussi une nouvelle option qui
va apparaître sur l'application tout
senti qu vide qui va vous alerter
lorsque votre pass sanitaire arrivent
bientôt à expiration donc ça veut dire
vous aurez vous recevrez une alerte
votre page va changer de couleur vous
présenterez votre pas sanitaires pour
vous soyez bien au courant que vous avez
reste le temps de jour où dans une
semaine pour être un jour de votre
vaccination vous garder le bénéfice du
pass sanitaires et il y allume près de
400000 prise de rendez vous sur les
sites de fans forme en ligne pour des
rappels de vaccination un simple
évocation de la conférence de presse à
booster les prises de rendez vous donc
on s'attend évidemment est-ce qu'il y en
a plus important aujourd'hui je leur dis
aux français qui nous regardaient et
nous écoute vous allez pouvoir prendre
un rendez-vous dans les prochaines
heures du repas difficulté
monsieur les ministres arrivent pour
pour ses news c'est une petite précision
technique sur le passé terre à partir de
quelle heure le pasteur et il valide
pour les personnes qui ont effectué un
test négatif à partir de leurs
prélèvements quant à partir de l'heure
du résultat concernant la campagne de
vaccination pour les 5-11 ans ou avoir
que l'agencé européenne du médicament a
autorisé l'utilisation du vaccin razer
est ce que vous arrêtez comme ce fut le
cas les mois dernier monsieur blanc
caire à organiser potentiellement une
campagne de vaccination dans les écoles
primaires et une dernière question vous
concernant vous monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de l'avant sans terre
allez-vous des données sur les personnes
vaccinées à nouveau affecté ce qu'il ya
des différences entre les facs
reste qu'il ya des vaccinations plus
protecteur que dans les apps vous avez
des autres protections contre les formes
graves qui sont supérieurs à 90 95 % et
le rappel vaccinal booste encore plus
les joueurs préférés je voulais plus ou
moins 1 ou 2% tous les vaccins qui sont
disponibles les vaccins arn messager qui
sont disponibles pour le rappel de
vaccination sont aussi efficaces l'un
que l'autre c'est important de le
rappeler parce que on voit qu'un peu de
désamour pour le veau dernier suite à la
lettre qu'ils avaient été faites sur le
certains cas très rares 2 cardiaque chez
des gens très jeunes dans les conditions
dans lesquelles il peut être prescrit en
plus à 2012 désormais il n'y a pas de
sujet donc les deux vaccins sont
équivalents je le dis parce que c'est
important vous m'avez posé la question
de la validité du test dans le passât ni
terre c'est à partir de l'heure du
prélèvement
ça peut être intéressant technique un
test pcr et à partir de l'heure du
prélèvement sur la vaccination des
enfants on en est pas encore vraiment
vraiment à organiser campagne scolaire
peut dire ça en présence de mon collègue
jean michel blanquer je le redis d'abord
le conseil consultatif national
d'éthique la haute autorité de santé
ensuite livraison des vaccins destinés
aux enfants qui sont une dilution
particulière on n'utilise pas les même
vaccin que pour les adultes ensuite si
la décision était prise de rouvrir la
vaccination au coût 5 11 ans dans
quelles circonstances dans quelles
conditions et ensuite impossible elle la
vie sic suivra c'est je le redis c'est
pas avant le début d'année 2029
un point supplémentaire sur sur ce sujet
en complément c c'est pour ce soient
parfaitement claires ce qui est envisagé
c'est que ce soit facultatif les pays
qui le font comme par exemple unis le
font de façon facultative on sait qu'ils
ont des facteurs de comorbidité
supérieur au nôtre en touche en plus de
populations d'enfants que vous savez
notre cas mais en tout est donc
évidemment il y aura des recommandations
particulières pour les enfants qui en
ont particulièrement besoin mais toutes
les perspectives que nous avons ne sont
qu' à titre facultatif c'est important
de 2,2 veut dire parce que ceux-ci notre
notre aperçu donc y aura peut-être un
vaccin en une des 5 12 ans pourrait
parfaitement clair pour la suite tout ce
qu'a expliqué olivier ans si ça devait
arriver ce soir est facultatif
bonjour gourevitch pour l' agence
france-presse question sur les tests et
notamment sur la capacité des
laboratoires à des pharmacies à faire
face à l'afflux prévisible que vous vous
annoncerons déclenché d'une part parce
que la durée de validité des tests est
réduite de 72 24 heures pour les
personnes qui en ont besoin ils vont il
est trois fois plus est par ailleurs
monsieur blanc caire parce que on a vu
que dans les écoles l'objectif est que
vous aviez vous même fichier de 5000
test est vrai très loin d'être atteint
vous renvoyez en partie la
responsabilité sur les sur les parents
d'aller faire tester leurs enfants dans
les pharmacies ou les laboratoires qui
dont vont probablement faire face à un
afflux d'adultes est ce que ces
messieurs pas créer un engorgement et de
créer la possibilité pour les places de
rouvrir
sur la première partie de la question
nous avons fait réaliser plus de 3
millions de tests cette semaine on voit
que ça remonte parce que le terme et
circulent plus mais laboratoire les
pharmaciens l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé qui font des
tests sont capables d'absorber les
remercie pour la mobilisation on est
montés à des niveaux plus élevés en
termes de tests je ne sais pas si on en
est un très fort impact sur la demande
liée au raccourcissement de la durée de
validité du test d'un passe de 72 à 24
heures mais si il y avait une
augmentation nous suivrons évidemment la
demande en vain je le redis le meilleur
moyen de ne pas se poser la question
s'il sait faire vacciner c'est ce n'est
plus compréhensible c'est plus
compréhensible j'étais raison française
regardez la région bretagne c'est près
de 96% des habitants ma fille nabeul qui
sont vaccinées donc il ya des disparités
territoriales d'une région une autre il
faut vraiment arriver à monter encore
niveau de couverture vaccinale vous
savez si la cinquième vague et démarre
plus tard chez nous et chez elle est
beaucoup plus faible c'est ainsi que
chez la plupart de nos voisins c'est
parce qu'on a une couverture vaccinale
est beaucoup plus importante comparer la
france et l'allemagne il ya plus de 10
points d'écart de vaccination entre les
deux pays donc il est vraiment
fondamental de se faire vacciner quand
c'est pas parfait
et d'ailleurs ce point vaut aussi pour
le taux d'ouverture des écoles est ce
qu'on peut constater dans les différents
pays lorsque vous avez dit sur les
campagnes de tests dans les écoles c'est
vrai que nous proposons nous sommes en
capacité d'en proposer six cent mille 2
par semaine depuis maintenant la rentrée
et que c'était au tour de 200 milles qui
sont faites avec un certain nombre de
limites en action dit si on diverge
l'une d'entre elles c'est je le disais
tout à l'heure dans l'acceptation des
pins donc la nouvelle formule
premièrement va certainement augmenter
cette acceptation départ en première ou
deuxième membre et dans la suite de ce
que vient de dire oliviero ne peut pas
engorger le système puisque j'ai dit par
exemple que les 180 mille familles
touchées aujourd'hui par le phénomène
des classes famille se veut pas dire 180
mille familles dont l'enfant est positif
mais 180 milles qui aurait tenu
au cours des huit derniers joueurs à
entrer dans cette système là et vous
voyez bien que c'est un titre assez bas
par rapport à la capacité générale du
système à tester chaque chien
merci à toutes et à tous seuls c'est
très bonne journée
pourquoi
épaules